So tell us about your journey.
How did you know you want
it to be a doctor and this,
this whole path was really your calling?
You know,
I always say it was an accidental journey.
I don't think anything was super
intentional until maybe more recently,
but the whole point or path of being a
doctor really began when I was a child
and we took a trip to India. My parents
are Indian and we went to Calcutta,
which is a very busy bustling sitting,
bustling city in India.
And I just remember being stunned and I
remember literally getting up from the
airport all the way into the city,
just looking around.
It was my first trip there that I could
remember and just being shocked, stunned,
the poverty, the people, the noise,
the colors, the smells. It was just,
it was just overwhelming. And there's so
many things I remember from that trip,
you know, from meeting my family for
the first time or extended family too,
you know,
trying to speak in the,
and the most terrible way you can
possibly imagine and all this other stuff.
But the thing that's stuck for years
later was just people on the street that
were hurt. They looked like they needed
care and something in me at that age,
I was 10 and it was just like, I
want to, I want to help people,
I want to do something.
So it's very naive.
Everyone walks around saying they want
to help people and they want to do
something.
Okay.
Stuck as I went through high school and
then as I got into college and that's in
college, I had doubts and I
had moments where I'm like,
I'm not sure if medicine is for me.
I love science, I love chemistry.
I love thinking through all of that.
But I also love writing and I love
speaking and I was thinking maybe more
journalism.
Maybe that's the way to go.
And at the end of the day I chose medicine
and embarked on that path and that
journey, which consumed me quite
honestly and left journalism behind,
left riding behind and read a book
and write and do anything for years.
And it's just funny how life works out.
Journalism found me again.
So that that was sort of the path to
becoming a doctor and to entering this
field. Absolutely. That's so interesting.
And not only are you a
doctor but you really, um,
in a profound way combined western
medicine, eastern medicine.
So can you talk a little bit about what
Skype did? You too, not just, you know,
do the traditional medical route,
but you know,
explore this whole other world that,
you know,
may not be as familiar to most people.
Yeah.
So that also is an accidental journey.
I never intended to jump into the world
of eastern medicine or integrative
medicine.
I was a hardcore Dr. Quite honestly,
I loved procedures.
I love adrenaline.
I want it to be an ICU doctor.
I interviewed across the country for
Icu fellowships and the only reason I
detoured from that was there was a lot
of stuff going on in our family back in
Atlanta.
And I was like,
I really need to be home for a year
or to settle all that stuff down.
Let me go back to Atlanta.
And I took a job in urgent care.
And so from urgent care I got recruited
into the emergency room and the
emergency room again is high
adrenaline, right? You're everything,
you're seeing everything you were
doing procedures and you know,
you see everything under the sun and you
meet every type of person under the sun.
So I liked it. I actually really loved
it. So that's the type of doctor I was.
But unfortunately the
years of medical school,
the years of your work or taking a toll,
and I didn't even realize it.
I wasn't even conscious or aware
of it. I was completely, you know,
disconnected from what
was happening with me.
I was more interested in kind of what I
was accomplishing or what I was doing.
And the kind of silent was
first that I always talk about.
Like you don't feel quite right.
Your joints are hurting a little bit,
you're starting to gain weight and
you can't really explain it. You know,
everything that was kind
of just very silent,
kind of murmuring under the surface for
years started to crescendo to the point
where I was losing hair.
It was noticeable.
I was gaining a significant amount
of weight. I had terrible acne.
I didn't feel good.
I would get dressed in the dark because
I was just so embarrassed to like try to
put myself together.
And then I still didn't connect.
I still didn't connect that something
was wrong and I needed to do something.
It's just I was so in my
head most of the time.
And it was finally a couple of things.
It was my mom,
he was really proud of my original Indian
hair cause I have the best hair in the
family.
And it was absolutely devastated.
But now like half of it was gone and it
was my now husband who we were dating at
the time. It was just like,
something's wrong with you.
You need to get checked out, you know,
I, you know, he goes, I don't care.
But like I feel like something's wrong.
And it was my patients, you know,
because the Er at some point is
still primary care nowadays. Right.
So there are patients that would come
in and had seen me for a few years and
they were staring up at my scalp.
They weren't really looking at
me or paying attention to me.
And so it was kind of those three things
that motivated me to start this journey
of trying to understand
what was happening, what was
happening with my health,
what did I need to do.
And that began my journey
for finding answers.
And that journey didn't go
really well. It, you know,
it was so frustrating and you know, not
to jump ahead, but I've been, you know,
to deal with my leather and long right
now who has a new diagnosis of cancer.
I'm back in that conventional medicine
world and that journey hasn't changed for
people. It's just as hellish
as I remember it being.
And I went from doctor to doctor trying
to get answers, trying to get solutions,
solutions and didn't really get anywhere.
Went to the quote unquote best
doctors in the city, you know,
it was willing to travel to get answers,
nothing.
And then finally got put on a medication
that one of the side effects of the
medication was that it
dropped my blood pressure.
Now I'm telling the story not just
to tell you what happened to me,
but also that explain how disconnected
I was and I was a physician, right?
So I'm put on this medication,
I'm following what I was told to do.
I'm not paying attention or digging
into the fact that, you know,
this might drop my blood pressure,
my blood pressure is already low.
Shame on me for that. Right? I already
have this knowledge. So anyhow,
I dropped my blood pressure dropped
dramatically one day while I was driving.
And so I got into a wreck.
I could have hit somebody else,
I could have hit another car,
I could have died.
And so that was sort of just the jolt
of like, you know, like what am I doing?
You know?
And so that began a search for answers
that began going home that day and being
like, I've got to figure something else
out and I've got to do it on my own.
There's really nobody else
who's going to do this for me.
There's no prints coming in. There's
no magic solution. There's no one pill.
So I just started studying,
I studied everything I could get my hands
on and it began with a weekend course
and holistic medicine. And
then that became, you know,
wanting to be certified in nutrition
and that became wanting to learn Chinese
medicine.
So I flew to San Francisco and became a
licensed acupuncturist and study Chinese
herbal medicine.
I learned about Iyer Veda,
which was a little bit in my roots
and got reintroduced to that.
And then finally did the
integrative medicine fellowship
with Dr while which has
an Arizona.
And so spent two years going through
that program and that kind of finally I
finished that program,
I think it was 2008 that gave me the
confidence to put like all these little
pieces I had back together in terms of
maybe taking care of somebody else. Now,
all the information I had gathered up
until that point I had fixed myself.
It took me a good two years, but I
had fixed myself. But then, you know,
it was everybody else asking
questions like, what'd you do? Well,
how did that happen? What was
the solution there? You know,
what or would you take it?
What do you do acupuncture for this.
So all those questions and then finishing
the fellowship, that was sort of,
you know, the kind of the
moment where like, Hey, I might,
I might have something here. I might be
able, might be able to help a few people.
So, so that got me into the
world of eastern medicine,
integrative medicine,
functional medicine, nutrition,
all these different fields
that you hear about today.
But that was my entry into it.
Absolutely. No really interesting journey.
I think wellness is such a buzzword as
everywhere and it's kind of just the new
fad. So how do you define wellness and
how do you break down some of those
stereotypes or misconceptions that
are out in the media and you know,
in our everyday lives today? Yeah,
I feel like wellness is such a,
a used term now, right? Everybody's
talking about wellness in our vernacular,
which I think is great. I mean, I think
it's fantastic that we've shifted from,
you know, disease management to
wellness. I think that's a huge,
huge accomplishment culturally.
So that's fantastic.
But wellness means different
things to different people. Right?
And it depends on who you're talking to.
I remember him coming from this vantage
point in this perspective of having all
this different types of
training kind of under my belt,
including conventional medical training.
And so when I sit back and I think about
what does wellness mean to me and what
does it mean for my patients or from
my center or for anyone that I touch,
it's really cumulative.
It's additive.
There's not one factor
that defines wellness.
And so it's really the accumulation
of a number of different things.
And I would start with energy,
like where's your energy?
If you have good energy,
your emotional landscape. I mean, I think
the further I get along, it's funny.
It's like I know so much chemistry and
I know someone's physiology and I'm sure
we'll talk about all of that.
But the further I get along,
it's like I'm understanding
how powerful our emotions are,
how powerful our sense of connection is.
That's a part of wellness too.
I think it is chemistry. It's
your nutrition, it's your
biologies, your physiology,
what's your gut doing? Do
you have inflammation? It's
all of those things as well,
and then it is about community and
family and support and spirituality.
All of those things define wellness when
that is the reason I think that so many
people send my exam rooms or my offices
or talk to me when I'm out and they're
like, well, I don't understand. I
ate this way. I did this, I did that.
Why did I get x, Y, and z? It's because
again, it's cumulative, it's additive,
and it can feel overwhelming
to try to tackle all of that,
but unless we start to sit back and
understand that it's all influencing each
other.
You know,
I had an expert tell me recently that
a hamburger on vacation is metabolized
completely differently than a hamburger
when you're stressed out or you might be
eating it right now. So, I mean, again,
it's like it's so cumulative and so
additive and we have to understand how all
those pieces come together.
And the beauty of eastern systems of
medicine is that they stress that from the
get go. It wasn't just, you know,
take this herb. It was like, well,
what's the rest of your life doing?
And then trying to understand how to put
all that together. I love it. I love it.
Um,
so you know,
obviously western medicine hat then what
would be like a hack or something that,
you know, um, you know,
is a general tip that you could give
to some of our viewers or audiences?
I know that, you know,
our worlds are so crazy,
but if you could do one thing today,
what would you suggest doing? Am I god?
Besides buying super woman? Right. Well
I think the first thing I was stressed,
you know, and it's funny cause I think
my answer's changed over the years,
but I think the very first thing I
would stress is the importance of being
connected to yourself.
I think that's the most important thing
you can do to not ignore yourself.
I think most people and most women in
particular ignore the soft and silent
whispers that we here on any given day,
they'll ignore the fact that I'm tired
more days out of, out of, you know,
out of the week, then I'm not, you know,
or that something's hurting or that my
hair's falling or this joints bothering
me or why am I gaining weight or losing
weight either direction, you know, um,
more so than I ever have in the past.
Or Why am I suddenly getting
more anxiety or depression?
I think we collectively
ignore those things.
And I think the most important thing
before you start any health or wellness
journey is to understand how
to get connected back to you.
I would say that's the first thing and
there's so many different ways to do that.
I mean, that's a really big
blanket statement, right?
But it's everything from just adopt
one habit that you could do everyday.
Maybe you journal every morning, maybe
you pray everyday, maybe you meditate,
you know, maybe you go for a walk in
nature. You know, but whatever it is,
have that conversation with yourself in
whatever format you want to because I
will bring you back to yourself.
So that would be my first kind
of foundational starting point.
Then we can keep building
from there if you want. No,
it's great. I mean, you know,
Googlers are often high
achieving individuals, um,
are constantly, you know, plugged in,
dealing with many
different levels of stress.
So what do you do to unplug
or any suggestions for when
you feel like you're on
that brink of burnout or you feel
something coming along, you know,
besides getting in touch with yourself,
what some things that maybe you
like to do? I think, you know,
it's so easy to get burned out when
you're a high achiever because you want to
accomplish a lot. I still want to
accomplish a lot. I'm far from done,
but you have to watch your energy and you
have to watch kind of your boundaries.
And I think it's so hard to do because
there's always that goal or that next
milestone that you're, you're
trying to get to, are trying
to accomplish. So again,
I think one of the things in
your schedule, put the breaks in.
I think you need to put in
breaks throughout the day,
especially for you guys,
right?
Cause you guys are on technology a lot.
And I think that in
itself is very draining.
We're learning more and more about the
effects of that as we get further along.
But I think putting those breaks in,
I would take three 10 minute breaks
throughout your workday. You know,
where you are forced to get up, get
away from computers, cell phones, iPads,
all that other stuff.
You know,
maybe walk outside the building for
just a little bit. Get fresh air.
It's amazing how just fresh
air and sunlight can shift
your energy very quickly.
So that's just a quick, easy hack
that you can do anywhere. So you know,
those three, 10 minute breaks, I
would also strongly advise, you know,
this is so easy to do too,
but really put in your schedule a block,
maybe an hour to two hours a week to
do something that lowers cortisol.
So that means you know,
you're not running necessarily,
but you're walking or you're going for
a swim or you're doing yoga or maybe
you're just a nature for a period of time
or go ahead and schedule that massage
or acupuncture or something
along those lines.
Those are ways to recharge because the
biggest problem with high achievers,
and I'd be so curious to
see what everybody a Google
test out as in the power
type plan.
But the biggest problem
with high achievers is that
they never take time out to
de stress. You're in high
adrenaline mode all the time.
And the problem with high adrenaline
is yes you get stuff done,
but at some point you're
going to crash and burn.
And that crash and burn comes as
maybe mild symptoms. I'm just tired.
It's hard to get to work in the
morning to things that are so severe.
Like I can't move I, you know,
I'm depressed or things like that.
So you never want to get to that place.
So putting those natural breaks in,
you know, 10 minutes throughout the day,
two to three hours a week, you know,
where you're doing something that's
very different from your job,
but you're also doing something that's
forcing you to lower cortisol cause
that's the hormone that you
guys are at the most risk for.
And that could be any of the modalities
that do that, whether it's walking,
doing yoga, swimming, you know, doing
acupuncture or doing massage, you know,
any of those things
that force you to relax.
So those are probably my strongest
tips for that. Awesome. Love it.
And I know you said a really important
piece of this wellness journey is knowing
yourself.
Yes.
And you've actually developed a really
interesting way to know yourself a little
bit more through this idea of power types.
So could you talk to us a little bit about
the different power types and how you
thought of this whole methodology?
Yes, definitely. So again, you know,
I have all this different types of
training under my belt, eastern medicine,
Chinese Ayurvedic Nutrition,
you know,
and then at the same time I'm doing
conventional Western medicine labs.
And our office. So I'm looking at hormone
levels, I'm looking at nutrient levels,
I'm getting real data,
you know,
to match kind of what I'm seeing
with the other diagnostic systems.
And one of the things I
learned, you know, I've,
I continue as I sit with
women in particular, even men,
there's probably a book for then
coming soon. But, but even, but
what I've noticed is, again,
this, this loss of what to do,
they don't have a roadmap,
they don't have a plan.
And that was the question I get asked
over and over again. Like, you know,
it's classic go bring a bag of
supplements or they'll bring five books or
whatever. Like I don't know what
to do, please tell me what to do.
And so we're all different, right?
We're all unique, we're all individual.
But as I was talking to women and I'm
about 12,000 women in over the last decade
of seeing patients and you listen to
them and you're hearing their stories and
then you're interpreting data, the
pattern started the lineup, you know,
and so somebody who have this medical
condition and this hormone imbalance was
also this ayurvedic type,
this Chinese medicine Meridian imbalance,
this nutritional deficiency over here.
And I could start to see him at
a certain point in the practice.
And then I started to track them
and I started to write them down.
And when you start to write them down
and track them, then you're like,
oh my gosh,
there's something here.
We would have this powerful prescriptive
formula for empowerment really to help
us all feel amazing if we use the tools
of both and merge them together and we'd
be able to understand,
I think this is why I do this.
This is why I need to eat this way.
So that's how the whole
concept of power typing began.
So it started with a
bunch of spreadsheets. Uh,
probably Google spreadsheet
is lots of Google spreadsheets and
entered a lot of data just to track what,
what was happening.
And then as I developed the five types of,
these are five power types and they each
have a distinct way that they need to
eat, they need to move their
personalities tie into it.
Their emotional tendencies
tie into that as well.
There are know supplements that they
might need their hormone imbalances.
And so as I develop them, then the next
step was to name them. And so the names,
again I've stolen literally from
eastern systems of medicine.
So the five power types,
just to review them real quickly.
The first one is the Gypsy girl and the
Gypsies. My creative super creative.
Some of you may be Gypsies, but have
that Vata energy from Ayurvedic Medicine,
you know,
have that sort of adrenal issue where
they're more likely to go into adrenal
fatigue, have anxiety,
those types of things.
So there's a whole set of issues
that are both pros and cons that are,
that come with being a gypsy.
And the second one is the boss lady.
And that's your high achiever. That's
your go getter. You're commander.
The boss lady is amazing.
We have a lot of boss ladies we know
and apparently there are a lot of boss
ladies you know that are very
high achieving women in at work,
but they're the biggest
problem there is an IRS data.
They're more pitta and they hold all
their stress and their digestive system.
So the first thing to go for a boss lady
is usually something with their gut.
So Ibs, constipation, reflux, you
name it. But then that goes on.
And this is where modern science,
Intersex,
we know that all inflammation
today begins in the gut.
We know that in science we're seeing that
when we do research on the microbiome
and all that other good stuff.
Chinese medicine,
Ayurvedic Medicine had already
talked about that. So again,
if you knew this ahead of time,
if you knew you're a boss lady and you
know that you're going to hold your
stress in your digestive system,
that all the more important to be on the
right diet for you to protect against
inflammation, to protect against those
autoimmune diseases and things like that.
Uh, the next one is a blend.
And that's what both of us are,
we're both savvy chicks and that's a
blend of the Gypsy and the boss lady.
So part creative part go getter.
So at times we're probably lost somewhere
in space and at other times we're like,
go, go, go. Right. So, so it's the blend,
but then you have the medical issues of
both in the hormone patterns of both and
the nutritional needs of both.
Um,
I think after that it was the earth
Mama and the Earth Mama is the nurture.
I will say as the person that's like
the center of a home in the center of a
family. You guys probably know
in Earth, mama around you or,
or within your own families.
But they are the worst about establishing
boundaries and really attending to
their own needs.
They're usually worried about everybody
else and they defined themselves really
through everybody else.
But there's a medical consequence to that.
And that's what we find with Earth Mamas.
They often have issues with
insulin resistance, with
diabetes, with hypertension,
more cardio metabolic type issues.
They're the ones the most likely
to get depressed because again,
they don't have their own like foundation
and so forth. So that's the Earth Mama.
And then the last one is the Nightingale
and the Nightingale is that mission
oriented service focused person who just
is about a higher calling and a higher
cost. But again to the point
that they sacrifice themselves.
And so they may be your friend that's
on mission trips constantly and then it
turns around that they're getting like
pneumonia and bronchitis and like all
these different illnesses
over and over again.
It typically taxes their immune system,
you know,
that's the first thing that goes
for them. So you know, for them,
I've had a lot of Nightingale's and
practice as well and it's always reminding
them that the mission is important, but
the mission is only as good as they are,
right? So they've got to take the time to
rebuild their immune system. And again,
there's a diet that matches that.
Their supplements that match that
there's a certain way they should move.
They should not be running and doing
marathons and all that other stuff when
they're in that Nightingale phase.
So you know,
it's fascinating to help women understand
who they are, see them, do the plan,
and then see them make changes.
And then the other important thing
though is as women in particular,
at any given time, we may be any one of
those power types. We're going to shift.
We're hormonal creature,
so we're going to shift.
We may have a phase of our lives where
we're full on boss ladies, right?
But then we may switch and have a phase
where we're the earth Mama or have a
later phase where we're the Nightingale.
All of that's irrelevant, right?
It's more important for you
just to connect to who you
are at any given phase so
that you understand how to take
care of yourself and that face.
There's so many people. When I first came
out with this was, well, what's better?
Which is the best one? Which is
like the best one to be. I'm like,
they're all good. Every single
one is good. It's just the,
the point of this was to understand who
you are and really put some thought into,
hey, this is who I am and
therefore this is my roadmap.
And then once you have
that roadmap for me,
what I really wanted in writing this
particular book and the power type formula
is I wanted anyone who touched it and
picked it up to begin that conversation
with themselves to begin to
understand themselves. You know,
I'm not saying I have all the answers in
there for every aspect of their health,
but I sure do have a way for them to
at least begin that that road and that
journey so that you don't
waste five or six years.
Like I did like feeling bad about
yourself, not like going for it,
are doing everything you're
supposed to do. You know,
you really are just full fledged ahead
being the super woman you're supposed to
be. I didn't and I firmly
believe that. Yeah, I love it.
And you got the superwoman title
from your daughter, right? Yeah.
So this was a fun story.
So, you know, we were,
I had this concept already in my
head of types of women and you know,
it was tracking and doing all that
other stuff. And I think it was a,
we were on a car ride with my daughter.
We had just come from an event where a
lot of women that come up to me that we
know and has been making comments and
she was with me and we get in the car and
we're driving and she's like,
mom you need to write a book for women.
And I'm like, I do. And she's like,
yeah, you need to write a book. I go,
well what would you write? What
would you call it? You know,
and she says a old soul,
but she's like,
you need to write a book called Super
Woman Cause you're a super woman.
I feel like every woman I meet is all
talking about how you're a super woman.
So maybe you need to help
everybody else be a super woman.
Cause I just see you as
mom, you know. So anyhow,
so she actually came up with a
title. I'm like, you're right.
That's a really great ideas.
So we call the book the Super Women Rx,
and I dedicated the book to her
because it is her idea and her title.
And she helped me actually to
with the power type names as well.
And she took the test. She was only
eight I think when I started the concept.
She was a nine almost 10
when the book was published.
But she still goes in and takes the test.
I'm like,
half these questions aren't relevant
to you. She's like, it's okay.
I already figured it out.
I'm a gypsy is hilarious.
She's a cutie. I love it. I love
it. So we're at Google, right?
We're all about technology
and the digital world.
How do you think about digital technology
and how it integrates with medicine
today?
Or even the things that you do on a daily
basis or your practice or how you help
women? How much time
do you have? Well, no,
so you know,
I am the biggest technological
idiot you've ever met in your life.
So my tech support when I was like
21 was my nine year old sister.
So I never thought I'd have to spend
as much time thinking about technology,
but it is a reality of today and it
has absolutely impacted our business,
is impacted the practice as impacting
patient care quite honestly.
So technology is a must and I have
forcefully had to immerse myself in that
world and try to understand,
you know,
how this piece of of the equation
fits in into what I'm doing.
And here's what I think.
I think that technology is amazing.
We need technology to track that, to
track our data, to track our numbers,
to help remind us of habits and
behaviors and to help with resources.
We absolutely need technology for that.
And I think one of the limitations that
even I'm experiencing with this type of
medicine that we're
doing is, uh, you know,
there's not a central place to get this
information right. It's not coming out.
So a lot of it is having to come out
of my mouth or something that I write.
It would be amazing to have this stuff
available in real time for women,
so they understand, okay, I just
told you you're a gypsy girl.
And they'll go figure out your, all
the other resources you need, you know,
and we continually updated.
So I know that there's a need for that
type of technology that is resourceful
data tracking, motivating, educational.
There's that from a practice standpoint,
what we have noticed,
and we're actually developing our own
platform because it's such an issue,
is that to do the medicine that I'm doing,
there's not the technology out there.
So it slows me down from a practice
standpoint and it prevents my growth.
So for medicine to really move forward,
we've got to have systems that
integrate all the information, right,
that put all the information
together, you know, and,
and really help patients with the
full picture of their health. I,
I define wellness for you earlier.
Well that technology needs to
match that definition, you know,
and it needs to be able to show
people this is the cumulative additive
properties of your health,
this is what your wellness looks like.
And it's taking all of that into account.
And then from a operational standpoint,
with the practice and with the,
with the business,
it needs to mirror that as well.
Right? So that's where we are.
We're trying to develop a platform so
that we can then take this medicine,
make it more efficient,
make it scalable,
and then allow it to
grow beyond just Atlanta,
the few centers that we have in Atlanta
and be able to grow beyond so that women
everywhere it can have access to it.
And then same thing with, you know,
the super women theory.
We want technology there so that women
can continue to grow in that process of
having that conversation with themselves
and understanding who they are. Because,
you know, I love the books,
I love writing, but not that
many people read anymore.
Right? They want like, they
want quicker information,
they want to download it faster.
So the book is a great foundational step,
but the next step is probably
technology slowly. Super interesting.
And I know you mentioned
this idea of expansion.
So what's next for you for the center?
What are you most excited about
in the next six to 12 months?
Maybe in your personal life at centers
space, but also in the medical world,
what excites you and gets you out of
bed every morning? Oh my gosh. Um,
there's so much.
I think that in the medical world it's
fascinating to continue to watch the
intersection of genetics,
new food and nutrition and all these
other data points that we've been talking
about for years.
How they intersect and
are really redefining what
prevention is and redefining
what healthy is. You know,
so the conventional world
needs some time to catch up.
But what's super exciting is seeing the
integrator worlds and the functional
medicine world really start
to gain their spot. You know,
it really start to come into the forefront
and lead some of these conversations
on what prevention really means. What
does healthy really mean, you know?
And that for the longest time there was
just a one line or flat definition of
that. I think the other thing
that me out of bed in the morning,
just from a medical standpoint is I'm
a huge believer and family wellness.
I've lived in a situation where the
family was not well and the center of that
family all was the woman, you know? So
that's why I decided to start with women.
You know,
because when the woman is not healthy,
it reverberates out into her children,
her husband, her extended family,
her community, her, you know, her city.
And so I think it's so
important to shift culture.
We have to create strong families
and we have to create really unified,
healthy families. And it starts with
a woman. So what gets me excited,
and the challenge quite honestly,
is understanding that when
it comes to women's health,
there are miles and miles and miles
of work to do journeys to travel.
Because we historically have gas lit,
women's health issues,
women's health issues were always
brushed to the side because it was a male
dominated field when
western medicine was born.
So to really change what's
happening within a family,
I've got to change what's
happening with women, right?
And if I can change what's happening with
women than I can turn around an impact
that family.
So that's what gets me out of bed in the
morning is knowing that that's sort of
the framework from which I'm functioning
and I love it. And to this day,
there's not a day that I walk into my
practice and I don't learn something or I
speak and I don't learn
something from somebody I meet.
And it's just such a fascinating
journey as far as the practice goes.
And as far as I go,
I mean we're just going to continue
to grow and scale and expand.
We're trying to again,
use technology to make this old way of
doing things better and more efficient.
Right? Cause we're now in
a culture that, you know,
we can't sit and talk for two hours
about something. So how do we create,
this takes the old system of medicine
integrated with the newer modern medicine,
but then it's at the same time preserve
the character of the flavor but also
make it efficient and run the way it's
supposed to run. So that's our challenge.
So that keeps me going in the center
and technology is a big part of that
conversation.
So six to 12 months from now,
I hope that we have our technology rad.
I hope that we are opening in launching
maybe here in New York and La and other
places around the country.
And as far as I go,
I hope I continue to do the work that
needs to be done to get this message out
louder and louder.
Well that's amazing.
What a great mission and we're
here to help and support. Um,
so we'll open up the floor for questions.
You know, as you're, as you're talking,
it makes me think a lot about the
obesity epidemic in this country.
Um, and how, you know,
I'm just wondering,
you know,
where does that all connect in here and
how do you think about bringing that to
folks who probably need it?
That's such a great word than maybe some
of us or some others. Definitely. I mean,
I think the obesity epidemic has happened
for a number of different reasons.
Probably the number one reason is honestly
our food sourcing and the production
of our food.
The more and more we dig into obesity,
we're understanding that a lot of what
was used over the last 30 40 years
between additives and
fillers and preservatives and
things like that have been
hormone disruptors and have
contributed to that conversation.
So when it comes to obesity,
again,
if we can educate a family on the
right way to eat in a way that's not,
you know,
everyone has a sort of preconceived
notion that eating healthy is expensive,
right?
So if we can help families
learn to navigate that
terrain so they understand how
to make healthy choices. And again,
it usually starts with a woman, right?
Because the woman's doing the
cooking, the shopping, the buying.
So the more empowered you can
make the woman of the family,
typically it'll go out into the,
into the children and into the other
adults with the family to help with the
obesity crisis. Um, we just are
also a culture of over consumption,
quite honestly.
You know,
we're eating way more than we need to
eat and that goes to our children and it
goes to us as adults as well.
So helping people understand
what normal consumption is,
I think is a big part of it.
And that's where the whole conversation
on food waste also comes up, right?
Because we waste so much food too.
So the obesity conversation,
I know there's been a huge spotlight
with movement and activity. Uh,
I'm going to push back on that and say
it's honestly 80% food and it's only 20%
activity.
And I think that's where maybe we have
the conversation wrong to a certain
extent.
You know,
I do also think that technology is an
issue for obesity in the future. You know,
how are we going to take this tool,
this amazing tool that we have of being
connected to anyone anywhere in the
world and get information
at any given moment,
but at the same time
create some boundaries and
parameters so that people are
using it in a way that is productive and
proactive and not working against them.
So the biggest thing I've seen in
pediatrics, you know, which is another,
it's another one of my
medical love so to speak,
but is that children don't have the
boundaries to navigate technology.
And adults don't have the education to
help them navigate those boundaries.
And again,
as much as I know I've had,
I've struggled with that with
my two children, you know,
and what's, what's normal,
what's not normal, what's, okay. So I
think technology, I think food first.
I think our food is the
biggest problem. I think, uh,
looking at technology and looking at
how children are trapped in rooms,
a lot of the times they're not outside.
I think the overscheduling of
families as an issue too. I mean,
all of these things are factors that
play into obesity for sure. And then,
you know, when it comes to different
socioeconomic groups, you know,
helping them with food deserts in areas
that aren't getting high quality food.
I mean,
there's so many.
I could talk forever on this and I'll
probably need to stop, but, but, um,
but there's so many great studies,
like if you give a young child
any socioeconomic status,
if you give them salads and healthy
vegetables and all that other stuff,
they will continue to choose that. But
the minute you introduce like a high salt,
high fat food, their
palate changes. You know?
And when they did a study comparing lower
socioeconomic kids and their parents
and giving them food choices, the kids
actually chose the healthier foods.
The parents had been so acclimated to a
certain tastes that they chose the the
junky or foods, you know, so a lot of
how it training is happening, you know,
there's a lot that needs to take place
there. So I think it's education. Again,
I think it's change,
it's got to be changed in our industry
and our food processing and then creating
environments where children can
thrive and adults can thrive as well.
That's super interesting. Yeah.
What's your view on sugar?
That's another hot topic.
So sugar is probably maybe the number
one culprit and he had to as sugar and
salt. I think those are the two things
and and all the different forms of it,
right? Yeah. High Fructose
Corn Syrup, you know,
all the different sweeteners and fillers
and Splenda and all that other stuff is
probably the number one thing
there is sugar and everything.
So sugar is probably one of the biggest
culprits for the obesity crisis, I think.
And when you go back and look
at food manufacturing and
you look at what changed,
there are a couple of things that
changed, you know, 30 to 40 years ago,
the amount of sugar and sweet nurses,
one of them,
the amount of additives
and salt is another.
The third is the use of a certain
pesticides and chemicals in our food
manufacturing. Those are probably your
three biggest changes, you know? And I,
you know, I go into a grocery store
and sometimes I'm like, I don't,
should I get organic? Should I not get
organic? Should I get this tape set?
What are your tips? Or what do you do
when you go food shopping? So what we do,
I mean we're majority organic,
but I know that that's hard to
sustain and it's hard to maintain,
but I think it's again, the dirtiest
foods, right? The dirty dozen.
And that's on the EWG,
the environmental working group's list.
If you want to familiarize yourself,
those are worth buying organic.
But here's the challenge.
You know,
even even people that are eating
organic and buying organic,
there's so much cross contamination
that you're still getting exposed to
different chemicals, different
pesticides, different things. So again,
that's why being proactive and
being in the sort of integrative,
functional space I think is so critical
because it's hard to control your
environment even when you're being so
conscious and so careful and so deliberate
about your choices.
Sometimes it's very difficult just to
control the environment and our needs are
different than what they were.
We had an infectious disease problem
maybe 50 years ago, you know, we had,
we had different medical issues.
The medical issues of tomorrow are
going to be environmentally induced.
They're going to be toxicity issues,
you know,
they're going to be
diseases of inflammation.
Those are the diseases of today and
tomorrow. That's why cancer's on the rise.
That's why autoimmune
diseases on the rise,
so it's just so hard to navigate the
space that I think that the more you know
what your body chemistry is doing and
you're being as proactive as you can to
support it, you're going to have
a better, better sort of outcome.
All the way through. Yeah. Oh
absolutely. Super, super interesting.
I think we had a question. Yeah. Awesome.
Thank you so much for being here.
I read the book and loved it and
what I really would love to say,
you made it so accessible for someone
who doesn't have a medical background.
And I would love to hear any tips
or recommendations you have given.
There's just so much information out
there on health and wellness and medicine
and you even mentioned with,
you know, being a doctor,
having the medical background,
being disconnected from some of that.
So any recommendations you have,
just like navigating the noise and knowing
what's a credible source and where we
should spend our time. Definitely. I mean,
I think that's probably the hardest part,
right?
So it was trying to find the
information that you can rely on.
I think your first step is to find a
medical provider that you can have these
conversations with. Quite honestly,
you know, I think there are a lot,
there's a lot of noise in
the wellness space, you know?
So again, turning at that,
I'm trying to, you know,
uh, toot our own horns,
but turning to the integrative and
functional community where there's so many
great providers coming along and they
have worked really hard at getting the
conventional training, but also
getting the training on the other side,
so to speak, and understanding
how were those worlds intersect.
I think that's probably your most
efficient way of going about it.
Because after that, if you're
trying to navigate like, well,
I read this article over here
and it said to take those,
and I did this over here and it said
to take that, it's really difficult.
It's why I wrote the Super Women
Rx, honestly, because I'm over,
they're not integrative and functional
medicine providers everywhere,
but at least that's a start, you know,
like at least if you can understand,
and even in the book, remember their
labs for you to check, you know, there,
there's all that information for
you to advocate for yourself.
You know when you walk
into the doctor's office.
But I still firmly believe and you know
as many different types of providers as
there are in the health
and wellness space,
I still really believe that the physician
has to sit at that table and it has to
help direct those decisions because the
physician ultimately has the breadth and
depth of understanding of how one decision
will play into another and what sort
of all of that relationship is.
So I think finding a strong provider who
can help you navigate information will
be helpful. And then once you get the
main ideas, this is you, you understand,
you then do your digging
and your research and,
and anything else you want to do and read
other books to gain inflammation under
that main idea. You know, it's
almost like writing a chapter, right?
And like come out with that
main thesis about yourself.
And then underneath that you
can develop things out more.
Cause you may then find things at that
particular provider or doctor didn't know.
And that's okay. You know,
it's just digging deeper.
But the confusion comes when you know,
well,
do I need to eat for my adrenals or do I
need to eat for insulin or do I need to
like a Paleo or Vegan or gluten free?
You know,
that's where the confusion starts and
gets so frustrating to navigate. Yeah.
Great question. Yes. Um, this
is kind of following up to that,
but I think you're in the unique position
of having both western and eastern
medical background and training.
What do you see as the future of sort of
scaling these eastern medical practices
across western medicine across the
country when so many people are,
it's not widely accepted as you said,
and it's kind of,
it might not be as easy for,
it might not be easy for everyone or as
accessible to find someone who's trained
in both eastern and medical.
And if someone isn't sure
where to start with their own,
like eastern medical research
and how to apply it to Western,
like what do you see as the future
of the best way to go about it?
That they're the future of the
industry for asking about that.
First of merging eastern and
Western medicine is passion.
I've really feel like it's my purpose.
Like how do we,
how do we get this out there? How do
we get it in the hands of more people?
And there are different ways to do that
and there are different ways to bring it
into medicine and change the medical
model. So there are many of us,
I'm not the only one,
but there are many of us who
want to change the medical
model and want to see it
like more accessible to more folks,
you know?
So I think that is a definite goal.
And something that you asked me earlier,
what gets me out of bed in the morning.
I mean,
I think that's something that sort of
motivates me for you, that it's worthless,
right? Because you're like a
great, great, you're going to,
you're going to work on this
for the next 20 years. So, um,
meanwhile I have to live the next 20
years. So for, so for you, you know,
I think it's again put pooling together
as many different resources from the two
systems or finding providers
like me. There are others
like me that you know, do,
do console, sometimes you don't have
to be necessarily here in the city,
they're remote or things like that that
help provide you at least foundational
framework for doing that.
And again, you know the book,
the intention of the book was to do
that for you to help you begin that
conversation. And then again
underneath that, you know,
once you understand who you
are and what your needs are,
go ahead and get the opinions from a
Chinese medicine practitioner if from an
ayurvedic practitioner, from your doctor
and merge that information together.
But ultimately you want to find someone
to guide you through that process
because it can get very overwhelming
and confusing to get information from so
many different places. So I
think it's, you know, read,
read the book and see if that
helps you. I would say, you know,
try to find a practitioner that is well
versed in both to give you some guidance
and direction and then begin your journey
of exploring different aspects of your
health so that you can,
you can start to put some of that
information together for you. Hi,
thank you so much for being here.
Um,
I had a quick question about how you
approach the conversation with older
generations.
I think with parents and grandparents,
sometimes it can be harder to have
these types of conversations and the
education background and they're not as,
um,
I guess open to changing
habits or lifestyle.
Have you had older clients or can
talk through experiences where you've
approached it with parents
or grandparents, um,
that have been successful or any tips
for that? Yeah, what a great gosh,
and I've experienced this
one personally for sure.
We do have older patients
that come to the practice,
but they're are typically more engaged,
right?
They've already like done a little bit
of digging and research or they're a
little bit more open now and
within our own family, you know,
my dad doesn't listen to anything I
say. Um, he'll say, okay sweetheart,
I'll do that.
And I'm sure he doesn't do any of it.
So they're tougher because they come from
the generation of the doctor was right.
I'm going to do what the doctor said and
Pharmas best. That's their generation,
right? So they believe in their
medicine is transactional. You know,
you go to the doctor, you get a script
in your hand, that visit is now complete.
If you did not get a script in your hand,
there was no point to the visit.
So that's the generation that they came
from. So it's much more challenging.
So the best way to start is two or
three things I've noticed. Like, hey,
why don't you just try doing these
two things and not give them too much
information?
I've actually seen the reverse where
it's like somebody our age or younger,
they want the information, they want
to understand how everything connects.
They want to be empowered in an advocate.
The older generation doesn't
want all that they don't under,
they don't care about the connection
and the big words like inflammation and
oxidative stress,
they're not interested in any of that.
All they want to know is almost that
same transactional language. You know,
your joints hurt,
tried this,
and then you give them two things to do
and then you follow back up maybe after
give them two weeks and see if after two
weeks they were able to put those two
things into effect. You know?
So I would think, you know,
transactional is the only word that
comes to my mind. But simple commands,
you know, this hurts, do this, that's
not working. Try this, do those.
I've noticed that anytime I sit with
my mother in law and my mom or my dad,
any of them, and they're all so
different in their personalities,
but essentially the conversation
always goes the same way.
Anytime I try to connect the dots,
put the pieces of their health together,
explain all of this, I lose
them. You know? So don't do that.
Just to just be very simple and be very
direct and see if they feel better.
And oftentimes we'll get results and then
that motivates them to move on to step
two or step three. I'd try
that. Come in for you grandma.
Have crowd. Yeah, go for it.
I have a question on,
uh, technology again. Um,
so there are like so many apps now to
like can track your steps or your workouts
or calories or a turndown you're the
blue light on your screen after a certain
time, right? There's all
these friends writings.
So I guess do you have any advice to
new people in this room who may be
designing apps like to use?
Um,
or for the rest of us who we use all of
these things like, um, how to navigate it,
how to design better,
you know,
how to incorporate like a holistic thing
because I think it right now it gives
like almost a false sense of
connection role. Yeah. Like, oh well,
like my phone told me to stand up today,
so like I'm great.
Like I'm dying on the fitness journey.
That's such a great question.
And I have seen that, you know,
people rely on their data. I,
they come in the room and they were like,
well let me show you.
I know I'm getting rem sleep cause my
sleep tracker set up getting rem sleep.
I'm like, why is your sleep tracker in
your room? But anyway, but you know,
I see that all the time. It does.
It's, it's good and bad. It's not all,
it's not all either direction.
It's good because you're getting data,
you're getting information,
you're getting sort of an initial
look at what you're doing, you know?
But it's bad because it's not the whole
picture. Right. That's the bad part.
So I think anyone who's designing
anytime they can design,
and I challenge myself with those two,
anytime you can design to where you're
trying to bring in the whole picture in
some form or fashion,
if you're designing a sleep tracker,
well maybe ask a few more
questions around sleep. You know,
just because they checked off on they
got this many hours of rem sleep does not
necessarily mean that they're healthy
or that all that sleep quality was good.
You know?
So maybe you know,
working with somebody who has sort of
this well rounded approach who can bring
more of the whole picture into any of
these and then take p taking some of these
folks were using data and
using apps through workflows
that if this is happening,
then you may want to consider this,
this and this.
Not Turning into a doctor's
office necessarily, but hey,
have a conversation with your doctor.
You might want to get your labs checked,
you know, or you may need to eat, drink
more water, you know, whatever it is.
But having that more well rounded approach
where rather than just fixating on
one or two day data points is going to
help the patient on the other end of that
be more successful in the long run. Yeah.
So I don't know if that was helpful.
No, it is interesting because there
are so many dare so many right now.
Just because you hit your stacks
doesn't mean that you're healthy.
It's a great way to check in with
yourself, but it's not accomplishing like,
who am I? What are my
main needs? You know,
what do I need to build
under that main idea?
And I know you went over it in the book,
but you know,
if I was going to go get
a blood test tomorrow,
what would be the two
or three top you know,
signals that I should be looking for.
So I mean I can answer that very easily.
I think the number one thing
we're not checking for routinely,
which every doctor should be
checking every patient for
our inflammation markers.
They're easy to do. They're covered by
insurance, but checking like a CRP, Esr,
which is a set rate, uh,
look into homocysteine.
Those three things you should
be doing every six months.
Cause to me those are the earliest
warnings that something is wrong with your
body and something's not quite right.
And then the investigative work can come
after that. So that's one for women,
I think it's so critical to
look at your hormone levels.
I talk about this all throughout the
book looking at estrogen, progesterone,
thyroid,
the derivatives of those hormones
because then it tells us what your body's
doing with them and you want to do them
periodically. Cause you want to track it.
Speaking of data,
you know you want to be able to track
it because it was normal for you is not
normal for me.
So you know,
you might feel really good at a Tsh of
two but I feel good at a Tsh of one.
You know,
so when five years from now you have a
baby or something happens in your Tsa
shifts and you're quote unquote normal
by the conventional range but you feel
like crap, then we can go look
back and say, oh no, no, no,
that's not where your TSH needs to
be for you. So I think, you know,
tracking this data,
tracking these labs,
that's the beauty of technology
is tracking it over the
course of your lifespan
and knowing where you felt great,
where you didn't feel so good.
And it also helps you later when you
guys enter sort of the anti aging or kind
of the more prevention conversation
because then we know where to correct you
back too as well, you
know? Totally. I love it.
Well thank you so much. You are coming.
I know. We're all really excited.
So given them
[inaudible].